I don't know which country is paying
Tucker Carlson to promote Islam, but he
is worth every Qatari realal. For more
than two decades, we heard nothing but
racist, Islamophobic, hate-mongering
bigotry from Tucker Carlson.
>> You know, there are a lot of
well-educated, affluent Muslims in this
area around DC. But I've seen a bunch of
polls like this that show that the
attitudes of faithful Muslims are not
western at all and that they include a
tolerance of violence you don't find
among say Presbyterians. I I think that
in every Muslim majority country in the
world non-Muslims are treated uh have
fewer rights. Men and women are not
treated equally under Sharia right now.
>> But everything changed in 2025 as he
started mocking people for their
concerns about Sharia. So they get rid
of all
>> Sharia law is bad, Seth. I don't know if
you've heard that. It's bad. It's worse
than what's happening in New York and
Detroit. It's just bad.
I don't know why. Just like years of
brainwashing. I just like Sharia law.
Well, in
sorry Sharia law. Now he says he's never
really had a problem with the idea of
submission in Islam. I remember who it
was. Come on. And be like, you know,
Islam is bad. And I was like, sounds
bad. You know, whatever. I don't know if
I ever met a Muslim. But he's like, you
know what Islam means? Submission.
And like let it hang in the air. Like
that was self-evidently disgusting. And
I was like, I kind of think submission
to God is like the whole point of life.
But I didn't say anything. I was like,
I'm I don't think I'm against that
actually.
And Muslims are absolutely loving their
new hero, the pro-Islam Tucker Carlson.
I have not seen transformation in media
personality like Tucker. May Allah guide
him to Islam. May Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala guide him. Amin Amin. Subhan
Allah. Even those who built their carers
criticizing Islam have grown to respect
Islam and its teachings. May Allah guide
him to Islam. A mean Allah has a
mysterious way of putting his creation
to the right path. Subhan Allah. Tucker
should just say the shahada. He is so
close to being Muslim. Brother Tucker.
Tucker. I used to hate you, but you're
on the mend. I'm beginning to like the
new you. I like this guy. I bet you do.
We can talk about Sharia in another
video. Right now, I'd like to take a
closer look at Tucker's fondness for
Islamic submission. I'm I'm I don't
think I'm against that. Actually,
anyone who submits to God, like I'm just
for that.
>> This is DA level nonsense, but it's
coming from one of the most popular
conservative commentators on the planet.
Da, in case you're new here, is Islam's
version of evangelism. But it involves
deception, tricking people into
converting to Islam. And one of the most
popular Dao moves for decades has been
claiming Islam just means submission to
God. You believe in submitting to God,
don't you? So why would you be opposed
to Islam? Islam is just submission to
God. You agree that we should submit to
God. So what's your problem here?
That's what we heard over and over and
over again from Dwagandists for decades.
Now we're suddenly hearing it from
Tucker Carlson.
>> Kind of think submission to God is like
the whole point of life.
>> Now Islam does mean submission and in
its religious context it does refer to
submission to Allah. So why would we
have a problem with submission?
Well, the most glaring problem should be
that we're talking about submission to
the God of Muhammad.
This isn't submission to the God that
Christians believe in. So before you
start telling millions of people that
submission to Allah is wonderful and
amazing, you might want to take a quick
peek at what the God of Islam says. To
keep this as simple as possible for you
Tucker fans, I'll just point out some of
the things the Quran says about Tucker,
who identifies as a Christian, and about
his non-Muslim fans. Surah 98:6,
verily those who disbelieve in the
religion of Islam, the Quran, and
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him from
among the people of the scripture, Jews
and Christians, and al- Mushrakun.
Mushrakun are people who associate
partners with Allah will abide in the
fire of hell. They are the worst of
creatures.
Jews, Christians, and other non-Muslims
are the worst of creatures. We're lower
than pigs according to the Quran. But
Surah 310 says that Muslims are the best
of peoples ever raised up for mankind.
Muslims are the best of peoples. Tucker
and his non-Muslim fans are the worst of
creatures.
Surah 3:32
say, "Obey Allah and the apostle." But
if they turn back, then surely Allah
does not love the unbelievers. If you
don't believe in the apostle, i.e.
Muhammad, Allah has no love for you.
Surah 5:51.
Oh you who believe, do not take the Jews
and the Christians for friends. They are
friends of each other. And whoever
amongst you takes them for a friend.
Then surely he is one of them. Surely
Allah does not guide the unjust people.
Muslims aren't allowed to be friends
with Tucker or his non-Muslim fans.
Surah 48:29.
Muhammad is the messenger of Allah and
those who are with him are severe
against disbelievers and merciful among
themselves.
Muslims are severe against Tucker and
his non-Muslim fans and merciful only
among themselves. In surah 9 29, Allah
commands Muslims to fight those who do
not believe in Allah nor in the latter
day nor do they prohibit what Allah and
his apostle have prohibited nor follow
the religion of truth Islam out of those
who have been given the book. Those who
have been given the book are Jews and
Christians until they pay the tax, an
acknowledgment of superiority, and they
are in a state of subjection.
Tucker thinks it's a good idea to submit
to a god who calls for the violent
subjugation of Tucker and of all his
non-Muslim viewers.
That's a problem. Islam isn't submission
to the God who entered creation and died
for our sins. It's submission to the God
who orders his followers to attack and
subjugate you for simply believing that
God entered creation and died for your
sins. But there's another problem. Islam
doesn't simply tell you that you must
submit to the God of Islam. It tells you
how you submit to the God of Islam. If
the message of Islam were submit to God,
Jews and Christians would have no
objection. But the actual message of
Islam is here's how you submit to God.
In Islam, you submit to Allah by
mindlessly accepting anything Allah and
Muhammad say and by unquestioningly
obeying Allah and Muhammad, even if what
they're commanding sounds completely
insane or totally evil to you. Let's
read two verses. Surah 33:36.
It is not for a believer, man or woman,
when Allah and his messenger have
decreed a matter that they should have
any option in their decision. And
whoever disobys Allah and his messenger,
he has indeed strayed in a plain error.
Here Tucker might love the idea of
having no option once Allah has decreed
something. But we also see his messenger
here. The messenger is Muhammad. You
can't be a believer if you object to the
decrees of Muhammad.
This is even more explicit in surah 4
verse 65. But know by your Lord, they
can have no faith until they make you,
oh Muhammad, judge in all disputes
between them and find in themselves no
resistance against your decisions and
accept them with full submission.
Notice, you can only submit to Allah by
fully submitting to Muhammad and having
no resistance against any of his
decisions. Tucker and Dwagandists
everywhere tell us Islam is just
submission to God.
And how are we supposed to submit to
God? By mindlessly obeying Muhammad.
And who was Muhammad?
Muhammad was a man who married a
six-year-old girl. A man who took the
wife of his own adopted son after
causing the divorce by lusting after
her. A man who tortured and executed a
guy to find out where some money was
hidden. Right before taking the guy's
wife back to the tent to make her submit
to him sexually. A man who bought,
owned, sold, and traded black African
slaves. A man who told his followers to
beat their wives into submission. and a
man who said, "I have been commanded to
fight against people till they testify
that there is no god but Allah, that
Muhammad is the messenger of Allah, and
they establish prayer and pay zakat, and
if they do it, their blood and property
are guaranteed protection on my behalf,
except when justified by law, and their
affairs rest with Allah."
Islam calls for the violent subjugation
of Tucker Carlson and all of his
non-Muslim fans. Conservatives defending
or promoting or praising or admiring
submission to Allah and Muhammad is
every bit as insane as queers for
Palestine cheering for Islam.
Submitting to this God in this way is a
really, really bad idea. Conservatives
used to understand that. Tucker used to
understand that. But it's a brave new
year when the ideology that calls for
our violent subjugation is being
promoted not just by Dwagandists, not
just by the far-left, not just by
politicians pandering for votes, but by
Tucker Carlson and other conservative
commentators.
I hope it's worth it. Now, for those of
you with a bit more common sense and
integrity than we're seeing from Tucker,
I'll say this. If you want to submit to
God, good. It's a good idea to submit to
God. But just because you want to submit
to God doesn't mean you should be stupid
about it. And what you definitely
definitely don't want to do is get a
huge platform and dupe others into being
stupid about it. because we're all going
to stand before the Almighty one day and
give an account not just of what we've
done, but also of what we've convinced
others to do. People with huge platforms
need to be very, very careful about what
they do with the influence they've been
given.
[Music]